I said are you a fan of Kim and Kanye or
do you hate them no I love I mean Kim
Kardashian has you know her she's a nice
person there's like a canon of work I
can refer to necessarily but Kanye I'm a
huge fan of his music and yeah he and I
used to we used to have the same
personal trainer so we would we would
work out next to each other yeah which
was bizarre
yeah he's a big fan of comedy and he
likes our stuff so I tried to return the
favor by liking his stuff this is the
original bound to this is the two of
them close your eyes and let the word
paint a thousand pictures one good
a thousand [__] Pam
man
this is you and James Franco recreating
that shot-for-shot chopper close your
eyes and let the word paint a thousand
pictures
man
someone had to have they been in touch
since I actually I read into him and one
of the things that disturbed me is that
we spent more time making our video than
he spent making his video yeah it was
like three days to get it right he's
like man we did like four hours yeah he
he's a fan of it he thinks it's funny
and yeah I've run into him a couple
times actually since we released it so
figure out that his verbs know if it was
quite funny he thinks it's funny he
acknowledges it's a weird video stylist
I don't think he thinks it's like
thriller or anything like
have you never said it's what are you
gonna do something really have you never
met a Spice Girl I'm wait hold on
have you never met a Spice Girl God in
the flesh
okay when you when you forget your line
you kind of go